by the power of gasol hate skull i am
somebody actually imitated me doing that
a guy named corey i believe it's corey
philpott could be totally butchering his
last name but he is
an extreme endurance athlete he did like
a iron man triathlon with a
log on his back or something crazy like
that um
i'm going to come back to him at some
point i featured him on here actually
with one of his videos but he uh
randomly did a story where like
somebody's filming him and he comes in
he's like i'm hella marc
and i just get a kick out of that
because imitation is the highest form of
flattery people how are we doing are we
exercising i can ask you that because i
am exercising despite all the
difficulties in my life that i'll get
into so many profound difficulties and
barriers just to doing the most basic
things um
you know part of being an adult is just
doing things that you don't want to do
and i consider exercise one of them
because you're not always going to
want to exercise and i experience that
more than you might imagine it doesn't
get
much easier it does get easier if you
have a habit but
i'll just say that
when you get sick for example and this
is going to be the first thing in myself
for i talked to casey about this before
we started the show i said you know
the only thing i have listed here is
bronchitis
and i feel self-conscious about
making my life about things that
happened to me because i don't like
portraying myself as the victim of
sickness and uh
i was telling a little story about my
freshman year of college there was this
kid who lived across from me
who happen to be openly gay and
flamboyant and this is relevant to the
story just because the manner in which
he dealt with
having a cold
i remember
stuck in my mind as sort of the opposite
of how i would ever want to
inform other people of any sort of
illness that i had i remember i could
hear him he lived across the hall from
me
and he
went out from his room into the hallway
to make a series of phone calls to
seemingly everyone in his rolodex to
inform them that he had a cult likes
it's one of those things like
he calls them hey how are you
i just have a cold i'm like super
stuffed up and you know over and over
and over again and i just remember
thinking at that ripe age of 18 years
old don't be the guy who's constantly
telling people that you're sick in order
to procure sympathy
right
i would rather have success than
sympathy maybe you want that too but the
fact of the matter is
i think i got bronchitis in
arizona we went to phoenix i went with
uh brendan to his shows out there really
fun time but anytime you're flying and
you're interacting with a bunch of
people you just up your odds of sickness
during the uh
pandemic
i didn't mean to question
the pandemic yeah it was a pandemic i'm
just saying like you know the
the sort of the phrases that you might
use to describe that period of time i
guess are kind of loose it's like people
will be like the lockdown the pandemic
the covid
you know the barriers of that
time frame are sort of nebulous but
during a good chunk of that time most
people's travel and interaction with
other people was so significantly
reduced and in my case it was
that you just don't end up getting sick
at all right you don't get you know end
up getting the cold
or anything like on this very long
stretch of time without so much as
getting a cold and then all of a sudden
i had
covid and then now bronchitis back to
back and i say bronchitis i thought it
was just like a normal cold or i thought
i was going hoarse from talking so much
and then i realized that there was
certain symptoms like a deep
sort of um
cough in your your lungs it feels deep
down in your chest
and you have
a nasal drip but it feels like there's
more mucus going on in here and
um you know the symptoms just matched up
all say that and so you know when your
lungs are filled up with mucus and and
you have this deep disgusting cough
you don't necessarily feel like working
out but i have to say
when i look at my entire life and the
opportunities that i've had
to either
work out or not when i don't feel like
it i've
i can
never really think of even one workout
that i've regretted doing i may have
regretted i remember i didn't feel up to
working out one time
when i was in high school and i because
i was sick and i forced myself to do
like an entire leg workout with
excessive volume anyway because that's
how i worked out back then
and it ended up making me feel like
worse like i had to lay down and all
this stuff which isn't the worst thing
in the world but
short of that if you can scale your
workouts
to how you're feeling and not push too
hard but still show up and do something
i've never regretted that and it also
helps maintain that habit so you don't
have to have that feeling of like now
i'm starting again right oh i took this
week off because i was sick
maybe you work out less frequently maybe
you work out less intensely but it's
just something that i felt worthy to
report on was the fact that through this
and it helps that i have workout
partners and people who ask me to work
out because maybe i wouldn't do that if
they didn't ask me but i'll say yes to
it and maybe there's other things that
you can say yes to rather than deny or
just say yes to that voice in your head
that's saying
hey you lazy piece of
beep
first three minutes right
no swearing watch you know watch these
numbers just go up and up and up the
cleaner i make this podcast once i start
catering to children and just opening
toys on camera we're going to blow the f
up all right so
main point of that was i got sick still
worked out here i am
you just you can't hold me down okay you
can you can infect my lungs you can give
me uh you know viruses that may or may
not be um man-made and uh a product of
uh chinese bio uh weapon factory
designed to undermine western society um
but you know you can't hold me as an
individual down because the individual
still reigns supreme suck it china take
that lock down shanghai
anyway what do you guys think about nfts
that's cool i guess that's the other
thing that i wrote down in my sup full
are you are you investing in nfts i'm
not okay you should i
still honestly don't really get them
yeah neither do i but i'm working on one
now apparently
um
and i i'm like i'm somebody who's been
using cryptocurrency
for quite some time now
definitely not to buy listed substances
off the dark web that would be crazy um
just for investment
purposes i remember actually going to
like when you had to buy it in person
i'd go to the store and the guy would be
like what are you buying all this
bitcoin for i'm like just saving it up
like oh you're buying a really specific
amount there
coming to buy like 40 bucks worth every
day you
what's funny is if had i kept all of
that or even half of that
i don't think i'd be podcasting because
i'd be a millionaire oops um
i don't know much about nfts other than
i i feel like you can sort of compare
them to cryptocurrencies in the sense
that it's you know
you own something that's digital but
unique
and uh
it could potentially go up in value like
anything else
that's determined by how much people are
willing to pay for it
uh my good friend nick ritchie who has
been on this podcast before he's the
writer director of 1-800 hot night in
addition to lolo
he has created a nft project that has um
it's
it's going in full swing he's
created a really interesting backstory
for this is one thing i didn't know so
i'm gonna go through like
nfts
i didn't know anything about them and
now here's what i do know that i didn't
know before they all have a story line
apparently like a backstory right
and so his
nft thing is the knights who say nah and
it's
like a collection of nights throughout
time who come together to like and their
purpose is to
you know inform people of the history of
knights and these artifacts that uh you
know are going to be involved in the
creation of you know these unique
digital images
what's nick's connection to this he
works for a guy who has some crazy
collection of
um
artifacts from these time periods i
guess the medieval time period you know
would be like
revealing how much how little i know
about history uh but he's got all sorts
of like
armor and swords and weapons and
different things
that
uh
you know are these unique historical
artifacts and i guess he's got some
title it's like you know he's got the
biggest private collection of medieval
artifacts
on earth or something like that you know
so this is how some people spend their
money
um
and
they're going to be using those to
create like they're taking pictures and
3d models of them to like like this
ended of itself it's like you can own
the nft of this
ancient sword or something like that and
so he recruited me
to do um some promotional skits with my
buddy boomer that we're gonna film uh
pretty soon here and
again had i not like known about or had
i
you know not been involved in this i
would know even less about it but this
actually does seem like kind of a cool
thing and maybe more legitimate than
other every time i hear about nfts it's
always like in reference to a celebrity
scamming people
right it's like
i've partnered up with this and this to
create an nft that's going to be really
helping the community in this and that
way
but like actually knowing nick and
knowing that he's like super
knowledgeable and passionate about these
uh particular
artifacts and he's you know he's had to
develop this expertise in order to like
um categorize them and and he like
restores them and and does a lot of work
with them that you know requires him to
have a certain
expertise uh
i i put that in a different category and
he seems he seems to be doing things in
the correct way and not just paying lip
service to the idea of like we're
helping this thing you know
it does seem actually designed to
bring attention and awareness to a very
specific set of historical artifacts
so when you guys see these
promotions drop on
instagram like share comment retweet hit
the subscription bell
all that stuff speaking of bells
you know do you know mark bell
mark smelly bell sounds familiar he's um
i always forget like in the fitness
world there's these celebrities and then
there's um other people who
i consider to be super well known
and maybe other people don't know them
but i watch mark bell's podcast he's the
inventor of the slingshot um
he
is uh
well his brother
chris bell made bigger faster stronger
and so marcus in that and i thought that
was an amazing documentary and um you
know he just seems like a cool guy he
reached out to me he's a former like
uh powerlifting record holder has some
insane numbers on equipped bench i think
like in the 800 pounds
and squatting over a thousand equipped
um you know in squat suits and stuff
like that but i think his raw bench is
actually close to like 600 pounds which
is pretty insane
and just a really interesting i was done
you know he's done the power lifting
thing now he's uh kind of got a more
more of a bodybuilding let's look look
him up all right
mark mark put up put mark there he is
yeah
so dudes jacked has a great sense of
humor
um
and yeah reached out to me to come up to
sacramento to shoot some content with
him whatever that means i don't know but
i'm i'm having fun
you know as as people
whatever find me i'm not sure exactly
how he found me but
it's always exciting when people that
you know
reach out to you and say hey let's do
some stuff and you're like i don't even
need to ask what kind of stuff we're
going to be doing let's just do it
and so that's what's exciting me
currently now
all right let's take a break from
talking about how jacked i am and how
jacked you can get if you follow my
advice to talk about happy hippo now i
use happy hippocratum
to podcast i use it to be creative i use
it to be productive it's my favorite
nootropic substance
so if you visit happyhippo herbals.com
and use promo code fickboy you can enjoy
some of this amazing kratom too mark how
do you use it well i'll tell you right
now
i dry scoop it i've used the pills um
i've used various mechanisms to ingest
this kratom and recently i've just been
measuring out about a tablespoon of it
because i calculated 0.025
grams per pound of body weight
and i said oh tablespoons about the
perfect dose for me pop it in my mouth
washed something down
with a little energy drink
and uh and i'm good to go so if you go
to happyhippo herbals.com
promo code thickboy3cs
get that 20 off for life a lot of people
have been asking me mark how do you look
so good today well i think you already
know the answer to that if you've been
watching the podcast it's
oakenstoneclothing.com where you can go
right now and get this shirt this is an
xl short sleeve gray it's part of the
new spring drop for oak and stone i
really love it
it looks classy it's really comfortable
it's breathable fits the arms just right
not too tight not too loose
i love the clothes
all the materials are super high quality
ethically sourced
it's a small business that you can go
support right now and support this pod
as well by using code hella at checkout
for 10 off and i guarantee you're gonna
like the clothes
uh if you're a girl if you're one of my
few female listeners i know you're out
there buy it for your boyfriend buy it
for your husband i guarantee he's gonna
like it too
and
if you don't like it you can call me up
we'll go on air we can discuss how we
can rectify the situation
i wanted to start off
the next segment
um hater of the week we're putting this
right up front
a little change in pace for the hate of
the week because this time the hater of
the week
is me
it ain't so much so oh my god spoiler
alert
don't tell anybody this if you're if
you're watching this podcast and plan on
sharing with anybody don't like share
them like oh my god the surprise twist
of this episode is mark's hater of the
week just let him find it let him
discover this
on their own and i think that'll be more
satisfying for now you could talk about
it with them afterwards but just keep it
under wraps okay
let's let the people have their own
moment of discovery and shock and awe
and disgust and then coming back to
realizing there's a hater in all of us
so let's click on that link right here
and i'm just going to walk you through
here we have the island boys what
happened to their hair i don't know was
it a wig the whole time
now are they twins it sort of looks like
they're twins right that's my assumption
but they never make reference to that
fact so it's confusing
we see one of the island boy
twins putting on a display of boxing
that is frankly embarrassing
and then he does a kick at the end he's
got these wild swimming punches now
casey i i mean maybe i'm crazy what does
that look like to you
dog [ __ ] dog [ __ ] okay
and
i i'm always confused by stuff like this
because i get it that not everyone looks
good when they
box
and that's something that i'll always
say like
people will give christian for example
uh [ __ ] for boxing but i'm like he looks
good when he's boxing you know what i
mean like he throws crisp punches and
anybody that can sort of like make
sparring look good or just hit in a bag
it's like that's impressive to me
because that requires a degree of speed
athleticism um you know body awareness
kinesthetic awareness whatever you want
to call it that um
does it translate necessarily to
fighting i i don't you know i can't say
maybe it does but
i think people don't have this grasp of
like how goofy people look when they're
trying to box and they're giving their
best effort and they can't you know
you'll see an athletic uncoordinated
people like steven a smith comes to mind
it's just like
atrocious and you go hey
you allowed this clip to be posted
online yeah what were you thinking it's
like you can see it you can right you
have eyes right like i mean you know
it's not like i walked in on your
private thing and it's like oh my god
you're like you're naked and you have a
small dick and i'm gonna tell the world
um
this is something that you said i know
what i'm gonna do with this footage this
needs to be seen by millions of people
because i'm a huge celebrity and i want
them to know that i hit myths
so my comment on this was you know
you're delusional when you first film
that second look at the footage
and think that looks dope and third
upload it to the internet oh you got it
right there
um
now
i talk about this a lot
that i know what it feels like to be
hater and in this instance you know i
felt like it was appropriate i didn't
feel like i was out of bounds but let's
just say 99 of the time that i have
those kinds of feelings or or those
thoughts in my head
i just check myself and i go you don't
need to post that you don't need to
comment that that's unnecessary these
are people too now it does help that
this was on josh thompson's page and not
on their page so i feel like they're
less likely to see it and i just like
not that i'm scared of them seeing it
but
that's what i think about is like
there's a receiving end of this comment
and i
you know
does that person need any extra
criticism in their life where are they
coming from are they coming from a place
of like i just want to share and
sometimes that is the case and you know
these factors play into whether or not
i'll comment and sometimes people like
will comment on my page and do something
like they'll refer to me in the third
person like he looks like this and that
i'm like i'm the one reading this
comment you know like it's directed at
me but it's like they're talking to
their friends or something or tagging
somebody else and i know that's pretty
common and i probably do that too
but like i realize it it's because you
create this like separation in your mind
and i'm i'm shocked that people do it to
me because i don't consider myself to
you know be a celebrity but it's like
if
i could see myself doing that to like
somebody that's huge that you feel like
you do feel this distance and therefore
you're like
look at that thing even though you're
communicating in a totally direct way
and that they can totally see if they
log into their own ig and maybe it's
different if they don't but like i found
it a bit jarring and strange and not
offensive but i'm like oh interesting
this person like doesn't think about the
fact that i read these comments and then
i go oh wait i do that too all the time
so here's me admitting that i'm a total
hypocrite hippocrates as andrew schultz
would say um
and i'm okay with that i'm okay with
having a little bit of hypocrisy and
just going you know sometimes it's just
it feels good to [ __ ] on people what can
i say um
so
the next segment i want to do
is a lot of people been asking me
let's look at this gigantic screenshot
here from sean kennedy three
he took the time to write me knowing
that i do respond to people it's getting
harder and harder to respond to everyone
because i'm taking on additional
responsibilities that i can go into
later um so sometimes i look at if i
don't know you or haven't corresponded
with you you know or i don't see
something like a work i do like workout
questions i do like favors certain kinds
of questions certain categories
even in this one like this doesn't
this is funny because part of me was
like i just wanted to mock the question
he goes dude how do i get jacked
pardon me right let's just explore these
options i want to go
um
here let me google that for you
something like that
like i don't know maybe go to youtube
use the vast abundant resources of the
internet
that you obviously have access to if
you're messaging me on instagram and yet
your first thought wasn't to google
how to gain muscle or even break that
sentence down into more specific
requests for information
you just said dude how do i get jacked
but at the same time
i do respect the honesty and the
directness and the lack of
self-consciousness that comes with it
with asking such a blunt stupid question
and i tried to give them you know a
direct response i said lift heavy
weights
and hit the major muscle groups at least
once a week eat a gram of protein per
pound of body weight get adequate sleep
to recover repeat this process a
thousand times
and i think that's
something that
the entire fitness industry or at least
people who are trying to profit from it
so i guess industry in general is going
to be biased towards misleading you away
from the most basic ideas right because
what do i end with repeat it a thousand
times well that's boring you know what i
mean um
i didn't make money off this interaction
but i did give him the principles uh
that he could use
to get jacked and most guys have those
basic ques how do i get ripped how do i
gain muscle super simple and the answers
are very simple if you're doing nothing
to advance those goals
and
i give you these basic principles you
can start with that and you can run with
some very simple exercises you can take
a list of
10 things would be plenty that you can
start on your path to gaining muscle if
you eat enough protein
you're gonna gain muscle um
if you
get enough sleep
you're gonna gain muscle right so
the entire fitness industry though is as
we see over and over again if i do you
know a fitness fraud or a charlatan of
the week
it's always the same theme which is
adding in
needless
complexity for the sake of marketing for
the sake of novelty for the sake of
looking cool
and
perhaps
showing off your athleticism or making
it seem like the reason that my body
looks jacked is because i can do these
ultra complex movements
which you know the two actually aren't
correlated at all you can have plenty of
muscle and be totally uncoordinated you
could have
uh you you could be fat and be super
coordinated and flexible we see you know
fat dancers all the right you see these
videos and people always tag me it's
black they'll tag chappelle ooh
chappelle while in
every single fat black guy on the
internet
somebody sends me a video it's chapelle
great original joke um
but these two things aren't really
coordinated and gaining muscle is
remarkably simple it's much more simple
than
you know doing anything that's complex
and athletic there's a video above this
a little link that i just wanted to play
real quick because
this goes into this principle a little
bit there we go
this guy featured before jeffrey verity
schoenfeld if you don't mind uh turning
up the volume on that you would
undoubtedly be bored out of your skull
so he says if you watch me do my whole
workout is usually about when it comes
to hypertrophy there's just not that
much variation it's not very
instagrammable and guess what most of
these [ __ ] posting these
instagram tick tock [ __ ] workouts
they don't even do that [ __ ] if someone
looks impressive regardless of if
they're enhanced or not enhanced or
whatever they're probably doing the same
basic [ __ ] they're just not posting that
because it ain't sexy and it's not gonna
get the clicks
couldn't agree more so to recap
he's saying
um if i were to show you my entire
workout you'd be bored out of your skull
and that's how i feel most the time when
i'm working out i have to remind myself
to take videos or add a little sentence
in to make something funny if i do show
a lift
because
part of me does feel very self-conscious
about just filming my workouts and
putting it up there because i feel like
that information is already out there
and maybe some people want to see more
of it i really don't have a great gauge
on that but
i want to add humor add something else
rather than just here's how i work out
because it is very boring and when i
look online to instagram and see
you know
either
two or three movements combined you know
like a lunge and a curl and a to a press
and all these things
it's unnecessary i would rather just do
like a circuit of all those individual
movements and focus on one at a time we
saw him doing bent over rows in that
video um
how much can you would you watch an hour
of me working out and taking all the
rest no it's much more flashy to do like
uh you know
jumping plyometric lifting weights
balancing uh doing something you've
never seen before so you know you're
glued to the screen just going like oh
what is that let me try that
that's an instagram approach that's a
social media approach to gaining
followers and i've shot content for
people and work with people who kind of
like who feel the pressure and i know
this because like
i've had conversations with them or they
they have expressed to me like the
pressures that they feel of like coming
up with new novel content and doing like
new exercises and in new ways and adding
some twist to it but that never ends you
know if that's your goal then the
pressure is always to like one up
yourself and you're not thinking about
what is best for my client what is best
the best information what is the best
practice for actually gaining muscle the
only thing you start thinking about is
how can i do this differently
how can i do something that hasn't been
done before but that's not the goal or a
primary concern of gaining muscle is
doing something your body's never done
before
in reality those simple variables like
using less rest time using a little bit
more weight using a slightly bigger
range of motion um or more weight and a
smaller range of motion um
or you know
pausing at the bot all those simple
little things that's all your body needs
as far as novelty right
uh you know doing a rep better with
better form is the novelty so
i like that message and just remember
you know getting jacked isn't about some
secret it isn't about some novel
approach it isn't about the new thing
there are only so many ways to gain
muscle and i'm actually going to go over
that probably next week but you know
it's it's
um
really comes down to
mechanical tension
damage to your muscle and metabolites
those are the only things that are going
to cause hypertrophy you can get you
know metabolites by like doing the uh
the the cutting off your circulation
training i forgot what that is but you
know you can take a really light
dumbbell and actually gain you know if
you cut off blood flow to your arm
um
you know not to the point that it needs
to be amputated but right before that
point you're going to get a lot of
muscle right before your arm falls off
um these are the only three ways that
your body knows how to do it your body
isn't going you know the fourth way is
if uh you do a different bicep exercise
every single day of the week but you
don't get a failure right so remember
that gaining muscle is simplicity and
repetition and that's why i say you got
to love what you're doing or you got to
at least not hate it it shouldn't be
punishment find something that you do
enjoy that you can repeat and if that's
not weightlifting
so be it if you don't want to get jacked
so much that you can't overcome the fact
that you don't enjoy weightlifting
that's fine but do something and i think
everybody can find something that they
enjoy that involves moving your body
right it shouldn't feel like punishment
it should feel like i get something out
of this that's positive and it doesn't
feel like i'm uh you know
a masochist right
oh my god
this is why we can't have nice gems we
got some links today
the title of this video is new gym fear
unlocked this guy's about to do some
shoulder press here jacks the weight up
onto his shoulder what's he got there
probably like 115s oh and it falls down
oh
my god
happens to the best of us right because
this guy is obviously a super advanced
bodybuilder he's got a great physique
tons of muscle kicks it up and he just
doesn't you know what are we blaming
here the faulty chair
we blaming he didn't check it this
couldn't have been his first set right i
don't think you just jumped to you could
but like i wouldn't just jump to weights
that big for
shoulder press with no warm-up
whatsoever so
good what do you think good bale by him
good yeah very very talented and this is
the thing it's like you got to be good
in the gym
like with failing right so you know like
not to throw it right in your face but i
could see somebody else that's why you
see people with dumbbells certain things
it's like ah you don't like you don't
know how to lift but you also don't know
how to fail which is an art in and of
itself to get these weights away from
you and make sure they're not landing on
your limbs
and
delicate
body parts
i.e testicles
let's go to the next one there okay
we got a guy planet fitness
and he's in the smith machine because
all they got is smith machines at planet
fitness and he's got reverse bands so
he's even lessening the weight on the
smith machine and if you're going to do
something like throwing up the weight
to give yourself room to clap the smith
machine would be the place to do it in
the first place because the
counterbalance creates this
you know this uh
uh bar path
that
kind of defies gravity a little bit it
comes up and down at a slower pace it's
not like you're throwing it directly up
in the air
it doesn't fall at the pace of gravity
right uh because the weight and the the
speed of the bar is lessened by the
whatever you know mechanism is going on
there do i know exactly what it is no
but
he's
[Music]
the elaborateness of this setup has me
tickled because
like who brings who's so advanced that
they're going to plan fitness with bands
in the first place right those are like
power lifting reverse pants
it doesn't have that much on and it's
like
instead of just doing push-ups with a
clap he's got to go in the bench put the
bands on put the weight on and then do
something that looks so easy you know
it's like
a tenth difficulty of a clapping push-up
so you just again i want to interview
these people i want to go what is going
on in your life that led to this moment
where you're bringing reverse bands into
planet fitness and doing
modified clapping push-ups like what we
would call this in his head you know
reverse
reverse clapping banded push-ups
come up with a name drop in the comments
let's see what you come up with
and again one of those things where i go
is this fake i don't know i i
part of me wants to think it is because
you can't be that dumb but at the same
time it looks real you know everything
about it looks real to me
here we go let's get the volume up for
this one
because hey bro can i work out with you
or how many sets you got three can i
jump into you and then he sits right in
his lap and i just like it's a gym prank
right it's not so much a gym fail but
i like that idea and i think i'm gonna
try cause what are you gonna do to me
you know i sit in your lap like
you're pinned and you're turned on no
matter what gender you are when i pop
that booty down
on your groin area okay this this one
with a little funny story behind it
so i posted this on easter now
i am not religious i don't celebrate
easter hate to break it to you if
anybody had an attachment to the idea
that i was uh you know
super orthodox in any way
not the case so i posted this thinking
it was funny
uh the guy starts off with a squat on
his back you know the first clip is him
squatting says i only carry the weights
on my back but
then it cuts to
a picture a painting of jesus with the
cross on his back
and what's the exact caption there i
only carry the weights on my back but he
carried the weight of our mistakes
now i posted that and some guy was like
messaged me some guy i don't know was
like thank you for sharing that
and i was like yeah man so funny
and he's like what's funny about it i'm
like ooh
because i don't i really don't want to
mock anyone's religion and i feel like
um
most of the time it's this not needed
like i don't need to personally belittle
anybody for you know
having any sort of religious belief that
doesn't interfere with my life and i
think there are times when you can
criticize people's
religious beliefs when they transcend
certain barriers but obviously this is
very innocent i just mistook the guy's
message for like thinking it was funny
or seeing the humor and but honestly
like whether or not the poster the
original poster of this um
video
meant it in
like humor or not it like and so that
made me rethink because at first i'm
like oh this is funny because he's
pairing jim and jesus i don't know like
what's your read on it do you think the
guy intended it as a joke who made it
i don't
but i could it's like because yeah
and i think on retrospect i'm like oh
you're right this was made seriously
like i'm so primed to be like ha ha the
idea of easter is funny to me you know
in a lot of ways um
just and in part just because of how we
celebrate it you know jim gaffigan has a
great bid on this where he's like oh
yeah jesus rose from the dead what do we
got how about eggs
um
bunnies and eggs and i get all that and
that's another conversation of you know
the remnants of of uh
pagan you know religious ceremonies that
make their way into
what we consider modern monotheistic
religions but
that was funny to me
sorry to the guy that
might have felt offended by that but i
think i saved it pretty well it's like
oh is this funny because it's such a
contrast between the like the gym and
jesus and it's unexpected and um
sorry but yeah i just i i i you know my
bad
we got one more okay this is awesome
just i wanted to set up that one with
one that i was confused about whether it
was a joke or not this is definitely a
joke and it still works and even if you
are religious i think you can still find
this funny
on the left we have jesus walking out of
his tomb this sunday after his death and
it's this jacked-ass bodybuilder doing
you know popping and locking
really well like if all bodybuilding was
like popping and locking during the
routine i would watch bodybuilding a lot
more because that still looks cool to me
and that turns something that normally
looks kind of stupid you know men on
stage and speedos posing like he made
that a hundred times cooler by popping
and locking what do you think comment
below does the popping unlocking make it
better or worse are you more likely to
watch bodybuilding if every single
competitor was forced to do popping and
locking during their posing routine or
would that make you less likely to watch
it
because part of it is you know i've
always felt like dancing it's in
having muscles makes looking cool harder
a lot of people don't realize this it's
like
the fact that you're bigger makes a lot
of movements like you just look less
elegant you know what i mean like even
notice this like when we think of like
really cool people
and maybe there's some modern exceptions
and i think like arnold schwarzenegger
kind of transcended that but like the
average super jacked guy looks awkward
walking around you know like if you have
really big arms like it doesn't look
good it looks sort of like eye-catching
and impressive but like you've seen
these guys in suits by the way like when
they do like the olympia press
conference and they all have to wear
suits and they all look like the kingpin
cartoon you know what i'm talking about
okay this is character and daredevil if
we can look him up um
there we go you see what i'm saying like
he's this guy he's just like this huge
giant guy with a suit on and he's fat
but also like supposedly really i
remember like you know the strength on
his marvel card was maxed out or
whatever
he's supposed to be really big and
strong but he just kind of looks fast
it's also six seven right he's supposed
to be this gigantic super strong guy
but that's i cannot help but think of
the kingpin every time i see these
bodybuilders in suits and maybe they do
that less so because they're also like
maybe that's like a 90s 2000s thing even
how the suits are tailored because now
like the slim fit is much more popular
but
bodybuilding for the most part looks
stupid you have to outside the context
of the gym
you kind of look ridiculous all the time
especially if you're an open bodybuilder
and uh
somehow this dude
dancing skills and just being black you
know which helps out being cool a lot
those are two factors that make me go
god damn and then
the the image on the right is satan
let's get it one more time
uh
the uh yeah satan realizing what just
happened it's this white kid just like
no
and let's picture jesus jesus right now
coming out of the cross like oh [ __ ] oh
what's up you tried to kill me oh uh uh
uh son of god here we go pop it and lock
it what's that oh front double bicep lat
spread
what do we got next oh my god so crazy
do we even have enough time for this
well
so
eat
i have probably told you guys
do i want to talk about celebrities all
the time no but did i break that rule
when i talked about will smith and chris
rock
slapping yes the great slapping of 2022
what are my parameters for bringing up
celebrity culture on this podcast well
it has to be something that relates
to psychology or some other principle
that i think is worth doing a deep dive
into rather than just
this happened isn't that crazy and
unexpected
boring stupid
i judge people who fixate on those kinds
of things sorry but you're probably not
that person if you're watching the show
i have to imagine and if you are
there's still hope for you to get better
the johnny depp amber heard trial
is something that i wanted to bring up
for the hella personality portion of the
podcast because
this would be an interesting time to
bring in
um a little segment on borderline
personality disorder
i thought you were going to say this
would be an interesting time to bring in
johnny depp come on in johnny come on in
that would be really cool actually and
it's so
where to start on this
in 2018 she released this letter right
she released this open letter and by the
way i got a recap of it this morning by
a guy named todd grande dr grande on
youtube and he does a lot of great
he's a he's a professional you know he's
a mental health professional doctor of
psychiatry i believe don't quote me on
that but he's super well informed and
speaks in a he has a really dry manner
of speaking but throws in some really
well crafted jokes that make his his uh
videos entertaining and i think he
really goes out of his way to be as
precise as possible and speak within the
confines of his expertise without saying
i'm not diagnosing anybody i'm just
discussing you know the possibilities of
what we could say in this you know he's
very careful to sort of give the
legalese but i like that because it's
true you can't diagnose anybody
without giving them you know without
being a mental health professional who
actually evaluates them properly so
these are all just
you know theories and speculations
it was interesting to me because at the
time
when amber heard came out with these
accusations
you know everybody's like oh my god
and my girl wouldn't shut up about it
she kept bringing up amber heard johnny
depp amber heard johnny depp johnny
depp's an abuser and i've been in you
know an abusive relationship and this
like
she would talk so much about it that i
felt compelled to ask her very politely
on multiple occasions can you please
stop talking about amber heard and
johnny depp i really don't care and my
approach at the time was
um
i wasn't there
it's probably he said she said she's
coming out to say all these things that
you know on the surface they seem out of
character for johnny depp but you never
know and i can't say that i know because
i wasn't there in anything we see
publicly or even if you release a video
that seems incriminating to one or both
parties um
ultimately
you weren't there for
99.99 of the rest of their interactions
to even know the context and i think
that's a mistake that
we make too like if you're in a
relationship
and something happens and you want to
explain like why you're the good guy or
why you know he or she's the bad guy
you forget that like people are
listening to you and you're telling the
story and you want to be like and this
is the pattern and this always happened
but it's like
the person listening to you
if they haven't observed that directly
or they don't haven't spent enough time
with both of you to really see this
it just kind of sounds like
you're venting and you know that person
can't ever
have your same experience because you've
been there with that person and have
your observations and that's still one
side of the story so you'd really need
sort of like you know security cam
footage of all these moments when
you know they think nobody's watching to
see what the real dynamic is and i just
think that's much more difficult to
really
get at
uh you know in a single story or a
single clip or whatever so i'm always
super hesitant and also just in general
like celebrity relationships who cares
they should be just as compelling as far
as the nuts and bolts as any other
relationship to me which is not very
much you know it's not compelling at all
because there's just so in so much
information especially when someone's
trying to persuade you like
it was this
you know dynamic always and in amber
hurts case it was i'm the victim of
abuse
now as you unpack that and you start to
go like
okay first i was just annoyed by it but
then other stuff started to come out
that was like this seems kind of counter
to the narrative
of johnny depp being the abuser
and amber heard being the victim right
and that was probably a couple years
after i know they had this like trial in
the uk that exposed a lot of stuff so
through these uh legal processes we got
more information
and started to see that you know there
was these funny incidents like
amber heard taking a dump on his bed and
wait did you know about that or not i
don't know about it okay right now i'm
like i don't like because i i was forced
to do a deep dive by hearing like
so much about it that i didn't want to
but that gave me the context when more
came out to be like oh this is the
opposite of what she was saying up front
right you got to be so mad to like take
a dump
yes i do yes
if you're using the dump as a weapon if
you're weaponizing dumps yes
um some other information that came out
that i thought was really interesting
was uh her assistant
who's there's some funny footage of her
this australian woman i'm sure she had
multiple assistants but
her assistant took a dump
i'm sure amber heard might have blamed
it on her assistant but she's like
you know
the during a deposition the legal team's
like so what did you do for you know
what were your responsibilities for
amber heard and she was like two minute
a list they're like what could you try
she's like are you ready for a really
long and she just went through like hey
she's like i've managed her whole life i
did this i did that i did groceries i
did like scheduling i did you know and
made it seem like this person was sort
of
exploiting her
and she only stayed in the job because
she had grandfathered in
the ability to pick up her son at a
certain time and bring him to work so
she's like i have a good gig here but
i'm definitely being underpaid and
overworked and this person mistreats me
on a consistent basis
and then you'd sort of notice that like
there was nobody saying that for johnny
depp like everybody who came out for him
you know had
his exes even all had positive things to
say and all seemed to say like the
opposite of what amber heard was saying
and as more information came out about
amber heard and her emotional volatility
and um her sort of self-centeredness
like she
for christmas one year she had her
assistant go out and like
you know the night before like through
this whole like list of like go get
gifts for every person i know and then
like scrap that all and was like
actually
mail them these life-sized uh naked
portraits of me
to every single person i know like like
the the gift this year is a naked
photograph of me like that's you know
six feet tall and you're gonna send that
to everyone as a christmas i just
thought that was funny on multiple
levels because it's like both
the you know narcissism of like telling
something
telling somebody something to do
uh and making it urgent and then like
scrapping it after they complete the
task and then being like actually
i'm going to do the most self-absorbed
thing any human can do which is
gift you an image of me that is so giant
it's going to be weird to even put it up
anywhere in your house
so
little things like that kept coming out
where it's like this person seems to
have sort of a bad reputation
at the time i remember reading about her
i'm like that sounds like borderline
personality disorder not a lot of people
know about borderline but when you meet
somebody who's had an experience with
another person who's borderline
you start to
see
these behaviors are like whoa yes
yeah that's the same thing there's all
these patterns and i thought that was
really interesting a lot of people think
it's
will mistake borderline for
bipolar because
borderline personalities tend to get
angry really quick and then can come
back down or have these mood shifts and
people go oh you're bipolar because
you're up and then you're down and
you're hearing that but bipolar is
really like a persistent state of mania
a persistent state of depression
and um
you know borderline personality is more
related to emotional volatility let's
just read through some of this stuff and
i want you to take this information
and apply it to when you see
amber heard
uh you know and any information that
comes out about her and how she behaved
towards johnny depp and even how she's
behaving in court what is borderline
it's a serious and complex personality
disorder seen primarily in adults
between 18 and 35 years old borderline
personality disorder is characterized by
mood instability impulsivity fears of
being alone or abandoned and poor
self-image for people with borderline
personality disorder everyday events can
trigger significant changes in mood and
emotional reactions clients who
participate in our intensive dbt which
is dialectical behavior behavioral
therapy treatment community often have
symptoms that include impulsivity
self-injurious behaviors or frequent
suicide attempts the symptoms of
borderline personality disorder can
result in mood problems but the illness
is not defined by changes in mood the
symptoms of borderline personality
disorder are relational people with an
untreated personality disorder tend to
use the same approach or personality
construct to cultivate relationships
repeatedly the lack of diversity in
interacting with other people can lead
to relationships that are confusing
difficult and extreme
sounds like giant epping her huh
in turn these unstable relationships
will result in isolation can cause
depression and anxiety in fact mood and
anxiety disorders frequently co-occur
with personality disorders among
patients who are inpatient hospital
settings 40 of patients with mood
disorders have co-occurring borderline
personality 40
of patients in hospital settings who
have
mood disorders also have borderline
let's just run through these symptoms
and keep in mind the one thing that i
remember now that
i heard and i was like ah that's
borderline
amber heard was super insistent that
when they were in an argument johnny
couldn't leave
he'd like
you should go you always bail you always
like you leave and we're trying to work
things out and
he'd be like you know you hear these
recordings he's like i didn't need to
cool down like you're being too
confrontational and aggressive and we
just need to like cool down and separate
and she hated that
you could tell like over and over
multiple conversations her number one
thing was when we're in a fight you
cannot leave me and that sounds like
somebody who thrives on
that high of an argument
and i'm somebody who's like i take
johnny depp's approach it's like if
we're arguing like how about i walk over
there and collect myself because i'm
about to do something that i might
regret
right and i can walk away from a fight
and and collect myself because if i'm
angry i don't want to take that out on
somebody and i'll try to isolate even
when i feel it coming and we're not in
an argument if i feel angry i'm like i'm
going to get out of here
and then come back you know when that's
calmed down so hear the symptoms intense
fear of abandonment or rejection
unstable or stormy relationships holding
a distorted self-image that constantly
influences their moods decisions and
priorities engaging in impulsive actions
like reckless driving binge eating
spending sprees quitting jobs leaving
relationships unsafe sex
wait are they describing me feeling
chronically bored irritable restless and
empty emptiness is another big one when
you hear people talk about like i'm
empty you know and they need to fill
that
void
with something that's exciting even if
it's a negative excitement thinking of
suicide or attempting suicide when under
stress experiencing intense anger
usually followed by expressions of guilt
and shame self-injurious behaviors like
cutting periods of disassociation
lasting from a few minutes to a few
hours
now
and i have some really interesting
little charts here
types of borderline personality
disorders petulant unpredictable mood
swings passive aggressiveness and a need
to fuel in control impulsive
uh binging risky and aggressive
behaviors self-destructive borderline
partaking and self-harming and abusive
behaviors discouraged fears of being
abandoned needing this emotional mood
swing so i guess you could kind of be
flavored in any of those directions
but one of them might be more prominent
the thing that i'll end on that i think
that that todd grande talked about was
the theory that johnny depp and even he
brought up this board i wasn't aware of
this until i saw this video and saw that
johnny was at some point mentioned he
thought she had borderline personality
her need
to paint him because you go where did
this come out of in 2018 why would you
they were already divorced and she comes
out and like doesn't name him but also
makes these accusations i mean what kind
of crazy person would do that now when
obviously you know you know who they're
talking about but you don't name him and
that's why he's suited for defamation in
the first place
the
uh
the theory here is
a borderline needs
the person that they're in a
relationship with to feel bad about
themselves they need to harm their
self-image to sort of justify being in
the relationship because
the person with borderline knows on some
level that you know
their behavior is wrong and abusive but
they can't
fully conceptualize that and internalize
like they need to be the good person
therefore any behavior that they have
towards that
the victim
it has to be
um
justified by well you brought this on
yourself
you're the bad person you're not good in
some way and you only can deserve me so
that the victim has to go like you're
right you know if you break that person
down enough and they believe you're
right the best i can do is you right
because you go why wouldn't johnny depp
just leave you has all sorts of
resources and options as far as women
yadda yadda this psychological dynamic
has to be set up like that so that
you know you feel like
this is your best option because you
drink the kool-aid of that dynamic
and
when
johnny depp then actually divorces her
that whole dynamic is shattered
and
she has to feel like
oh my god he really you know he realized
he wasn't
uh
such a bad person that i'm his only
option he realized he has other options
and that he's sort of better than me so
her response to that has to be totally
uh you know going all out to discredit
this person and say that actually you
know i was the victim the entire time
and that's the only way that she can
sort of
sew that entire relationship up it can't
end on like i left because i actually
can do better than you it has to leave
on no no
you're the bad guy i'm still the good
guy and therefore out of nowhere you
have this you know manifesto about
johnny depp
uh being an abuser which nobody else has
ever said about him in his entire life
oh my god
are we out of time did we like run
through the whole thing oh my god okay
well next week you can look forward to
seeing more about
rhonda patrick and saunas and
micronutrient discussions with uh
information from tyent clark
and
oh
we're going to go into some hair tips
okay because you see this right here
well actually it's not as great as it
could be but um you know i i wanted to
do a deep dive on some hair stuff today
so for now you're just gonna have to
look at it okay and
if you don't like looking at my long
hair if you look at my long hair and say
oh mark you should cut it your mom's
right
you can go short on the sides and long
on top and kind of spiky or maybe slick
it back like
you're actually the hater okay i'm the
guy who's just trying to live my life
and not do anything and like if my hair
offends you i think it just says a lot
more about who you are as a person and i
don't want you in my life and frankly
you should unsubscribe